[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia los actuales juegos olímpicos
de tokio son atípicos una cita que por
cuenta de la pandemia de coronavirus
escatima por primera vez en la historia
de público aficionado que aliente desde
las gradas a los 11 mil atletas que se
ganaron un cupo para esta la principal
competencia deportiva multidisciplinaria
del mundo los juegos olímpicos del mundo
moderno se comenzaron a jugar en atenas
a finales del siglo 19 un renacimiento
de aquella versión de los juegos
olímpicos de la antigüedad que se
jugaban en olimpia grecia entre el año
776 antes de cristo y el 393 de nuestra
era organizados cada 4 años desde
aquella primera edición en apenas de
1896 los olímpicos se han disputado en
diferentes ciudades del mundo como por
ejemplo los celebrados en los ángeles en
1932 miles de espectadores asistieron al
acto inaugural para aplaudir el desfile
de los atletas internacionales un suceso
en el que la ciudad
su ingenio creatividad millones de
dólares para inmortalizar la ceremonia
en la que el fuego de la antorcha
enciende el pebetero olímpico a
excepción de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio 2020 que fueron aplazados para
este 2021 por la pandemia de coronavirus
sólo tres veces y por ocasión de dos
guerras mundiales fueron canceladas las
justas en 1916 en 1940 y en 1944
paradójicamente antes de que comenzara
la segunda guerra mundial por la cual se
cancelaron dos veces los juegos
olímpicos quien fungió de anfitrión de
los juegos en 1936 fue la alemania nazi
de adolfo hitler su partido llevaba tres
años en el poder y para realizar los
juegos de berlín exigió discriminar a
los deportistas de origen judío africano
y de otros grupos étnicos pero la
presión internacional que amenazaba con
boicotear los juegos lo obligó a
permitirles la participación desde que
alemania fue la ganadora de medallas
olímpicas el afro estadounidense jesse
owens
y su historia al llevarse cuatro horas
de atletismo ante la mirada reacia del
twitter
como jesse owens grandes atletas han
pasado a la historia por su
impresionante desempeño en unos juegos
olímpicos
uno de ellos el denominado por la bbc de
londres y la revista sports illustrated
como el mejor deportista del siglo 20
mohamed alí a mohamed alí en su etapa
amateur se le conocía como cassius clay
su nombre original con apenas 18 años
este boxeador estadounidense pisó suelo
italiano para consagrarse con la medalla
de oro en los olímpicos de roma de 1960
le bastaron cuatro peleas en el
cuadrilátero para alzarse con el podio y
exhibirse a nivel mundial como un
pugilista prodigio de ágil movimiento de
piernas y contundente pegada fueron los
mismos olímpicos en que el etíope abebe
bikila se convirtió en el primer
africano en ganar la maratón 42
kilómetros en dos horas y 15 minutos con
la particularidad que los corrió
descalzo uno de los sucesos más
lamentables ocurridos en el contexto de
unos juegos olímpicos fue el acto
terrorista en los juegos de múnich 1972
tras el asesinato de dos atletas
israelíes y el secuestro de otros nueve
a manos de un grupo terrorista palestino
se llevó a cabo un intento de rescate
que terminó mal murieron los nueve
rehenes israelíes un policía alemán y
cinco de los ocho terroristas palestinos
cuatro años más tarde en los juegos
olímpicos de montreal 1976 una gimnasta
rumana de apenas 14 años nadia comaneci
se apuntó en los anaqueles de la
historia como la primera en conseguir la
máxima puntuación de 10 en esta
disciplina lo logró en las barras
asimétricas y desató una histeria
mediática la revista 'time' la calificó
de perfecta
[Aplausos]
conforme fueron pasando las décadas los
organizadores de los olímpicos fueron
derrochando en espectáculo y
ornamentación como es el caso de los
chinos que gastaron aproximadamente 100
millones de dólares solo para la
ceremonia de apertura de beijing-2008 en
el siglo 21 la fiesta de los olímpicos
ha contado en sus múltiples versiones
con un despliegue mediático que amplió
el rango de espectadores de la fiesta
deportiva en el mundo las más recientes
ediciones beijing-2008 londres 2012 y
río de janeiro 2016 han acogido turistas
del mundo entero que abarrotan estadios
bares y playas para festejar a
deportistas míticos como usain bolt el
hombre más rápido que ha conocido el ser
humano su hazaña fue en el mundial de
atletismo en berlín en 2009 donde
consiguió la marca de 9.58 segundos en
los 100 metros planos y tiene además el
récord olímpico conseguido en londres
2012 con 9 puntos 63 segundos en la
misma prueba reina del atletismo un
fenómeno jamaiquino que se retiró con
ocho oros olímpicos catorce medallas
mundiales y tres récords mundiales que
prevalecen hasta hoy y si el atletismo
es uno de los 33 deportes de los
olímpicos que más llama la atención otro
que también tiene una gran cantidad de
seguidores es la natación y en esta
disciplina no puede faltar la mención
del deportista olímpico más condecorado
de todos los tiempos el estadounidense
michael phelps quien ostenta el récord
de 28 medallas de las cuales 23 han sido
de oro su mejor actuación fue en beijing
2008 donde obtuvo ocho preseas doradas
convirtiéndose en el máximo medallista
de oro en una sola edición de los
olímpicos y también en el mejor nadador
de la historia ahora en los juegos
olímpicos de tokio el protagonismo se lo
lleva sin duda la pandemia de
coronavirus unos juegos que pasarán a la
historia por los obstáculos y las
polémicas que ha puesto sobre la marcha
la crisis sanitaria del cobi 19 así
concluimos soy andrés fares jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]